And then we got a quick squeak of the week clip because this is coming from Jake
Paul, um, who wants to fight Connor McGregor and called that his wife.
It'd be nice to see Jake Paul get his head peeled.
It'd be nice to just see him get his head knocked off by Connor McGregor,
because I understand, you know,
what you gotta do when he's very rich and famous and the kids got success beyond
success. I mean, that's his crab, you know, Timmy D knows him.
I'm sure he's a great guy, but I mean, you know, when you do stuff like this,
it just makes the people be like, okay,
I hope Connor comes out and knocked your head off. Even if he is a nice guy.
Yeah. And, um, also,
also, um, uh, yeah, it's um, you know,
he knocked out Nate Robinson, who's like a retired basketball player.
Who's not a real boxer. Right. So yeah, it would, you know,
I understand that America entertainment's become a little bit of a freak show,
so this would be nice.
It would be a nice thing to just kind of put an end to it. Right? Like
Connor McGregor was like, really hurt him.
Cause that's what would happen in that is like Connor McGregor would really hurt
him. You think he might do it? Connor McGregor? Is it possible you think? No.
No. I mean, it's like w w w what'd you got to gain out of it. I mean,
there's money there, but there's money there. If he fights a real person,
it kind of degrades the sport a little bit. I mean, you know,
but the good thing about Dana white and UFC is like all the guys that have
wanted to do it, like boxers, Dana, White's going like, yeah, come on,
try it out. Because the truth is MMA fighters are the real fighters.
They're the guides like, uh,
whether it's a great boxer and boxing's a great sport,
but at the end of the day, fights always, you always get your hands on somebody.
And that's why the greatest fighters are always wrestlers. I mean, look,
it could be BS, maybe the greatest of all time, you know,
Brazilian jujitsu and wrestling is always going to win out.
So Connor McGregor is gonna get his paws on his kid and he's gonna, he's gonna,
what would he say? He's gonna pound his head off the pavement, you know,
off the gun. But this would be, he's doing specifically a boxing match.
He wants to do with Conor McGregor, not UFC. Oh, well then you, I mean,
you know,
Connor McGregor probably did the best against the best boxer ever. I mean,
Connor McGregor, he's a celebrity make no mistake, but the kid can fight.
And when he lost to Khabib, he was on a two year hiatus and he was drinking.
So any, any one around. So, I mean,
Connor McGregor can fight for real. Like there's no question. He's legit.
Let's listen as Jake, Paul clamp. I mean, yeah. Let's listen to it. I mean,
John is YouTube.
What the is up? You Irish. Good morning. Connor McGregor.
I know you're probably beating up old dudes in a bar right now,
or maybe you're jacking off because you're sick of your wife. I mean,
she's a four counter. You could do a lot better, but happy Monday,
my team sent you a $50 million offer this morning,
$50 million cash proof of funds.
The biggest fight offer you've ever been offered, but you're scared to fight me.
Connor you're duck me cause you don't want to lose to a utuber your all-in-one
one is a boxer. I'm two and O is a boxer.
I just came off the eighth biggest pay-per-view event in history.
But you want to fight Dustin prober who has less followers on Instagram than my
dog. That's a fact. And Dana white, you're a.
You ugly bald.
You said there's 0% chance of this fight happening,
but there's 0% chance of you getting some Connor. You're scared. Dana.
You're scared. Sign the contract. You idiots. Jesus Christ.
Irish.
No, he wants to fight him. I guess, MMA. He wants to fight him MMA then. Right?
Well, I kinda, I I'm, I'm happy that Dana white and it's kind of like,
it's no comparison really, but it's kind of like, you know,
I understand money is money, but Dana white and UFC don't need the money.
It's kind of like when, you know,
if a comedy club or theater would turn around and say,
I'm not just going to put somebody to do stand up unless they actually do stand
up. You know, like that's what I think, Dana Weitzman. He's like,
I'm not just going to do this to do this. Like I don't,
we don't need your money. We don't, you're not a real fighter.
And I really didn't like the part where he talked about his wife, man, you know,
but I know Connor McGregor has talked about other people's religions and stuff
like that. So Conor McGregor's crossed the line a little bit as well,
but that's just stuff to people off. There's no basis in that wrong. It's just,
it comes off wrong. It just comes off. Like you don't talk about the guy's wife.
I mean, I mean, how desk, I mean, what have we become, man?
Like what have we become? Like that's just below the belt. I mean, you know,
I guess it's entertainment, but you know,
I guess nobody gives a what we have to say because we don't,
we're not fighting Nate Robinson. Bob is here we go. By the way,
we got an X-Box series X for all our friends and all our listeners X-Box series
X, you can win a free Xbox series X.
All you got to do is subscribe to both of our history, hyenas YouTube channels,
the regular page,
and the code phage and share a favorite episode or clip with a friend and post
screenshots of these two things to your Twitter or Instagram and use the hashtag
hashtag H H giveaway,
hashtag H H giveaway January 20th.
We will announce the winner of the day of Biden's inauguration.
We're going to announce the winner. Uh, as we entered to a communist regime,
we're going to give you a free X-Box of course tag the history of hyenas in
that. So we all see it hashtag HH giveaway. Do those two things,
get a chance to win an Xbox Xbox series X. Yeah. I mean,
who loves you more than us? Uh,
so make sure you do use that hashtag and Binky and Venet Tia will be
perusing and we will pick a winner and that's just what is going to happen.
[Inaudible].